13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
fear on the App Store or Google Play let
me tell you a weight-loss secret that
would change your life forever no it is
not exercising and no it is not a new
diet or special supplement it is about
giving yourself love you might be
wondering how can love relate to weight
loss well what should this video through
okay and don't forget to subscribe to my
youtube channel and turn on your
notification button so that you will be
the first to get notified whenever I
share a new video do you hear this
conversation playing in your head over
and over again gosh I hate the way I
look how can I love myself in this body
well when I've lost 20 pounds and gained
a flat belly that's when I'll let myself
even more
this constant self loss or punishing
yourself in hopes that you will start
loving yourself once you have achieved
your goal will only sabotage your weight
loss journey to make positive changes
you must learn to love yourself first
you have to love yourself even before
you can this weight and keep it off for
good it doesn't mean that you have to be
happy with your current body or state of
health but when you come from a place of
self love and acceptance your weight
loss journey would inspire you energize
you and make you feel proud of yourself
you're able to set realistic goals
celebrate small successes along the way
and accept the little setbacks and
disappointments that may come your way
so what should you do here are five
simple steps you can take to stop hating
your body and start giving it the love
it deserves
it's not just about the numbers on the
scale or trying to fit into that tiny
black dress of course that would be
amazing but try going beyond that and
set a goal that would drive you and
inspire you to want to make the change
and make this your lifestyle forever
perhaps you want to lose weight and be
healthier for your children and watch
them grow up or perhaps you want to run
your first marathon this year remember
goal-setting isn't just about coming up
with a plan it has to be purposeful and
meaningful for you to start making
changes you never thought you would be
able to so take this moment and
truthfully ask yourself what's your
purpose why is it so important to share
the excess weight off make a list of 10
to 15 things you love about yourself
include things you love about your body
do you have a pair of strong legs pretty
eyes what are your strengths as a person
don't just think about them in your head
literally write them down and keep your
list
close to you for instance on your mobile
phone or stick it to your mirror
remembering what you love about yourself
every single day
puts you in the right mindset to want
the best for your body now if you're
having trouble making the list think
about what other people you care about
have said about you or even ask them
[Music]
when was the last time you thanked your
body or perhaps this idea is something
completely new to you your body is a
marvel just think about it your body
never gives up on you ever you might put
it through some really unhealthy habits
such as constantly eating junk foods or
not exercising at all but it is still
moving and doing its things to keep you
functioning strong your body helps you
think and
carry out your work and favorite
activities so take this moment and thank
your body for making you the person you
are one-of-a-kind thank you buddy for
everything you've done and given me I
promise to continue to respect you and
care for you with love forgive yourself
and the way you've treated your body in
the past have you overeaten dieted
stuffed your body over exorcised or
perhaps not exercised at all that's all
in the past and you can't change it you
can however forgive yourself
and commit to start treating your body
with more love and respect don't worry
if you don't get it right for the first
time here's a secret nobody does keep
moving forward and keep trying because
this jenny would teach you to understand
and discover more about yourself
day by day it is not about being
stronger slimmer of fitter than someone
else why do that if it's only going to
make you feel unhappy or bad about
yourself we're all different and who you
are and what you look like is unique
your only competition is the reflection
you see in the mirror this is your
journey in being the best version of
yourself not someone else's self love
and acceptance starts from this very
moment right now hear this it is your
responsibility to yourself to live your
best life not someone elses so as you
begin your weight loss journey this new
year I just want to say to you you are
beautiful you are loved and you got this
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up like this video and
share this video on to inspire someone
and don't forget to subscribe to my
youtube channel and turn on your
notification button okay and be sure to
check out other nutritional tips fitness
tips and also workout videos on my
channel all the best